foreign
distribution in Las Vegas Bowl is a
college football bowl game for the Las
Vegas Community where we get to host two
great teams from the elite athletic
conferences and here to tell us more is
the executive director of ESPN events
and the Las Vegas Bowl of Johnson
well we'll see you again you've been
doing this for a long time how many
goals have you been part of this is my
21st which just means that I'm old no it
does not not mean it means that you are
experienced that's what it means and
this is very exciting I was telling you
I've been to quite a few of the Las
Vegas bowls and it's always a great time
and this is your second year at
Allegiant Stadium huh it is and and
luckily when we're out at Sam Boyd
Stadium usually when that sun started to
go back behind the mountains everybody
started to freeze yes nice and
temperature controlled cool 73 degrees
in there
um it it's it's been great to play there
well now tell us about this year's
matchup who
Vegas Bowl this year so uh coming from
the SEC we have the Florida Gators uh
coming from the Pac-12 we have the
Oregon State Beavers who Oregon state is
ranked 14th in the country uh Florida as
we all know is a huge huge power brand
out of the SEC
um you know every year perennial
Powerhouse so we're excited about the
matchup there'll be a lot of orange in
the stadium with Oregon State being
orange and Florida Avenue yeah it'll uh
it should be a good time well now it's
not just the game too there's a lot of
fun events leading up to it can you tell
us about some of the things that are
going on yeah and that's that's exactly
what we say it's more than just a game
we live here we work here we we love Las
Vegas we live in Las Vegas so we're
promoting the game all year long through
community events but when we get to this
week we have about 18 events built into
just the week oh wow and it's It's All
Surrounded about the players the coaches
the fans uh last night we took the
coaches to spago had dinner on the water
uh we had some charitable stuff this
morning I'm heading straight to Fremont
Street tonight for our welcome reception
action tomorrow's about the ladies and
the kids we take the kids the players to
a show or to go and see Matt Franco
tomorrow night more stuff on Friday it's
just it's a lot of stuff going on during
the course of the of the five days that
they're here and now you mentioned the
ladies and kids day they go to downtown
Summerlin yeah that sounds like
something fun and then what about like
the pep rally that's got to be a big
event too it is it and that's that's for
the fans right both teams uh are
bringing their full bands so the bands
love performing and they're going to
perform at Allegiant Stadium they're
going to perform it at the host hotels
which we have Mandalay Bay and Virgin uh
as the host hotels but uh yeah it it it
is it is everything that college
football is all about I can't wait now
how do people get their tickets if they
want to check it out real easy
lvbull.com we still have some available
they they these are two pretty good
traveling teams so they they've done
well they've they've already sold out
their allotment that we've provided to
them so now they're they're they're on
the sites trying to look for for tickets
but uh we still have some available but
lvbull.com get them while you can it's a
great time do not miss out on the SRS
Distribution well Las Vegas Bowl Florida
versus Oregon State December 17th again
for tickets it's a great time for and
more information go to lvbolt.com